Southside with you the new movie about  Barack and Michelle Obama's first date  in 1989 opened in theaters this past  weekend and I saw it I liked the movie  it was fine movie but I especially  enjoyed the subtle foreshadowing they  did of what was to come  in the future I thought that was cool  here's a clip what happened to the  meeting  it doesn't start so for I thought we see  some paintings maybe grab a bite to eat  hey Barack Obama  are you sure would make a great 44th  president we don't have to Brooke we're  not going out together and Michelle  you'd make a great first lady and a  great mother to Malia and Sasha I have  to correct we are in fact out and we are  in fact together you know who would make  a great president after you there's this  man Donald Trump  whoa  [Applause]  you